Magic
that was the season two finale that
stunned Ted lasso fans beloved assistant
coach Nate Shelley left to coach a rival
soccer team hated rival talk soccer team
and Ted lasso follows the improbable
Triumph oh by the way this is the full
background here probable triumphs of a
small time Kansas football coach played
by Jason Sudeikis and he finds
friendship and success coaching and
English soccer team the third season
follows a Fallout between Ted and his
new rival Nate played by Nick Mohammed
take a look well hey how about this one
regarding my panic attacks I've had more
psychotic episodes than Twin Peaks
I mean I'm so crazy
there we go
and Nick Muhammad joins us now Nick
thank you very much for being with us uh
oh he's wearing the Jersey I did not
expect that uh
so your character your character uh is
like the guy everyone's rooting for and
then kind of takes a turn to being maybe
the guy they're not rooting for and now
you're sort of in between actually
watching the beginning of this next
season how has uh the deception and I
want to give away the end of season two
uh that ended That season that you've
been aware of how did that affect how
you portrayed this character
well um I actually I actually knew where
the character was heading from from
really quite early on from when we were
filming season one back in goodness 2019
I think it was
um and I remember Jason particularly
sitting me down I think we're filming
episode three or four of season one and
saying look if we're lucky enough to get
picked up again for Seasons two season
three this is where we have in mind uh
this character going and yeah I went I
haven't given anything won't give
anything away for anyone who's not seen
uh season two yet um but um yeah you
know Nate absolutely starts off as this
Underdog character in season one a lowly
kit man and you know Ted comes along in
typical Ted style and empowers him and
yeah he eventually gets promoted to uh
to assistant coach at the end of uh
season one and it's a real joyful moment
for him but yeah things do then take a
slightly different turn in season two
Nicky I broke my heart at the end of
season two I just I'm still getting over
it
but I want to know from you what was it
like to kind of uh morph your character
because you really had to turn into this
more kind of bitter angry person how
were you able to do that
um
well I guess I mean if if I ever sort of
had any kind of sort of sweet spot in
terms of previous acting experience it
was in that sort of season one version
of Nate which is quite you know quite
awkward
um socially awkward bumbling comedy four
guy really but um
I don't know I found I found season two
increasingly you know there were a few
jokes really fewer gags for him and and
that was replaced by I guess slightly
more emotional and more dramatic
storytelling and it you know it was a
challenge it's not really something that
I'd done much of before
um and so I just relied on I mean look
the scripts were absolutely phenomenal
phenomenal so you know I owe it really
to to the writing team and the brilliant
team of directors and and you know Jason
in particular is so good at kind of
coaching performances really and kind of
making you find a truth to it and an
authenticity to it and so and you know
you're only as good as you know the
person that you're acting against and
you know getting to do scenes with Jason
and you know well the whole cast really
is it's been an absolute Joy
who I'm with Adriana on there I I have
to ask you this question how do you uh
sleep at night well sleep at night like
there are thousands of fans like myself
who really hate Nate right now you say
he's he's not a villain though he's a
victim and I I just don't get it explain
it to me sir
well I well I feel like you know every
villain has an origin story and you know
Nate is no exception to that I feel like
whilst I can't condone like personally I
can't condone his his behavior in in
season two in particular and you know as
we go into season three I feel like you
know in order to sort of Play It uh
realistically I had to sort of find a
real truth to why he was behaving that
way and you know a lot of it does stem
from this toxic relationship he has with
his dad
um and you know he was clearly bullied
when he first started out as um as a kit
Man by you know member you know some of
the players at the club in AFC Richmond
so he sort of has his reasons and they
might be unfounded and you know he might
uh you know he now he's been given a bit
more responsibility he's sort of
starting to sort of use it in in all the
wrong possible ways and so like I said I
don't condone it but uh but on saying
that it's quite fun to play and you know
you say that you're sort of hating on
Nate right now but that is correct you
know it was it was written that way and
so anybody who is hating on Nate don't
feel guilty you know you should be
feeling you know go easy on me on social
media as well
I love the new uh gray-haired look that
Nate has uh and you know I I don't think
he's a villain I think you're right he
is a victim I I do root for him even uh
for all he's done and also
congratulations to you Nick because
you're supposed to be here in studio uh
but your wife had a baby big news there
uh indeed yeah I wish you the best
little two-week-old
thank you gosh that is gorgeous well
next time maybe if there's a season four
you'll have to make the uh the journey
across the pond it's great to have you
here uh even remotely Nick Muhammad
everybody thank you very much season
three premiere of Ted lasso is currently
streaming on Apple TV Plus